hello this is Justin with the chess
website and today we're going to be
talking about the fjor witz variation
this is a very tricky line and it starts
with
D4 Knight to F6 C4 this is pretty
standard and then here we're going to
play
E5 now this is often known as The
Budapest defense but what differentiates
the fjora wits from The Budapest is this
next move Knight to
E4 Knight to G4 is usually the main move
but after Knight to E4 it sets up a few
more tricks and traps that your opponent
could fall into so first let's look if
they attack this Knight because if they
attack that Knight it immediately falls
into our trap so right away when they
move this Pawn they weaken this diagonal
now we have a a direct shot
towards the enemy King but we actually
we can play Queen H4 check right away
but we're going to actually throw in a
bishop to B4 check first and the reason
we're going to do this is
because typically white blocks with the
bishop and now we've sealed White's exit
this
way so if we play Queen to H4 check
now and then takes we can sacrifice our
Knights and when we take back with their
Queen this will be Checkmate again since
the bishop is
blocking White's King from
escaping and then after Knight takes G3
If instead of taking they took on
G4 black to move m in one black can play
Knight to E4 check M again we need to
control this Escape Square so the Knight
has to go back here to cover that
square so this is a very easy way that
white can fall into our our trap very
quickly but F3 is just not the best move
so most people will play a move like
Knight to
F3 and after Knights F3 um there's a few
things that black can do one of them is
to play B6
here which uh sets set up a trap and
another thing that black can do is play
D6 um which sets up a different trap so
it's really um you know a matter of
preference whatever you prefer um but
let's start with B6 B6 is really tricky
um because B6 is actually inviting white
to bring their Queen to
D5 so this is attacking this Knight and
also this Rook on
A8 so it seems very very good like white
is very close to just winning material
but here we're actually going to play
Bishop to
B7 so right away we defend the Knight
through the queen so Queen takes would
not make sense because we could just
take back and then if they take our
Bishop this is the big question like
what do we do now we just lost a bishop
but now we can play Knight to C6 and our
Queen defends our
Rook but we're still down a piece the
our Saving Grace here is that this queen
is very very close to being trapped so a
lot of people here will play Queen to
A6 and after Queen to
A6 we we could played Knight to C5 right
away but this would be a mistake cuz the
queen would
find shelter here on A3 it would find a
safe Square where it's not going to be
able to get trapped so instead of
playing Knight C5 right away we want to
control this A3 Square so we throw in
this in between move Bishop to B4
check that way whatever way uh White
blocks we can play Knight to C5 next and
now this bishop is controlling that A3
Square so this is a really nice way to
trap um white Queen here and so white
will try to go to the only other safe
Square which is B5 but here we could
play A6 but it's important that we
actually throw this in uh Bishop takes
D2 check because we no longer need to
control A3 because the queen can no
longer access that square so we're going
to get rid of that bishop and then once
white takes back we can play A6 so the
reason we do that if we play A6 right
away white would be able to play Queen
takes B4 and at the end of the day um
white would have three pieces two
Bishops a knight and a pawn so 10 points
of material for the queen which is a
little um a little scary what could be
in the driver's seat here but if we play
Bishop takes D2 check we've got a queen
for two pieces after something like this
and white takes one of our Knights um
we're just going to be
you know up a queen and usually that's
good enough to win the game so very nice
Queen trap if white gets greedy and
tries to play Queen to
D5 um all the way back here so that was
B6 but instead of B6 we can play a
different tricky move which is
D6 so this kind of makes a little bit
more sense because after this
move um we're invited white to capture
on D6 and we're going to take back with
the bishop so right away um we've gamed
a pawn right because we don't have an e
or a d Pawn anymore and white only lost
their D Pawn so we've GED this Pawn but
we're doing so because we're going to
have very easy development we can Castle
next turn well it's going to take white
one 2 three moves to castle at the very
least um so you know white might be
looking to Castle and play a move like
G3 but this again Falls right into our
trap after G3 we can play Knight takes
F2 and we are attracting the king to the
F2 Square so first off we are forking
the queen and the Rook so if white um
does nothing we would just take their
queen or their Rook depending on
whatever they save um um but if white
does take on F2 we have this really nice
move Bishop takes G3
check this is a discovered attack
because our Queen was attacking that
Queen was attacking White's Queen
through our Bishop and once we move the
bishop we're discovering um this attack
on that Queen so Bishop takes G3 is very
powerful and because it's check white
has no way to deal with a check and save
their Queen it's important that here we
don't play Bishop to C5 it looks like it
does a very similar thing but we're
actually inviting the king to protect
the queen and save it so we want to make
sure we take on G3 and again the key is
to control that E1
Square so after this move white is going
to take back and then we take on D1 and
again we have a queen for two pieces
which should be more than enough to win
so thanks for watching that was a quick
little guide into a few traps in the
fjor witz variation of the Budapest
defense let me know down below if you
have any questions and I'll see you in
the next video